[Music]
Disney Princesses have angelic voices
but do you know who deserves the most
credit for those fabulous singing
characters their voice-over actresses I
want to thank you for stopping that man
not many people would have done that can
you name the Mon keep on watching to
find out don't forget to hit that
notification Val to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's check out who's playing our fave
Disney characters Snow White let's start
with the og the one that started it all
the one that started the Disney Princess
dream
admit it a smile and a song still gets
stuck in your head we don't blame you
really but do you know who the person is
behind snow white's voice her name is
adriana caselotti Disney was looking for
a voice that's ageless friendly natural
and innocent and we can confirm
Adriana's voice is all of those things
but her story isn't exactly a fabulous
one unlike modern Disney voice actors
Adriana was only paid $20 per day for
her role as Snow White she didn't even
realize she was filming for a
full-length film unfortunately Adriana
passed away from cancer
but her Snow White legacy lives on
Cinderella and how could we possibly
forget about Cinderella a dream
[Music]
her story remains one of Disney's fan
fave even though plenty of people have
raised eyebrows at the whole shoe
situation but never mind that we're here
to talk about Eileen woods the woman
behind Cinderella's gorgeous voice I
hear you come on get off you say time to
start another day Eileen got her
Cinderella roll when she was in her 20s
but wait until you see what Eileen looks
like when she was older he made it a
happy time as I said going to work every
day was sort of like going to a party
isn't she adorable we absolutely love
her unfortunately Eileen passed away
when she was 81 but she seemed to have
been always thankful for her role of
Cinderella and let's be honest she
played it very well Aurora Aurora isn't
always a fan favorite
but we have to say we still love her
after all she made Disney history didn't
she Aurora's still one of the original
Disney Princesses so we have to give her
credit so who's the woman behind her
voice well her name is Mary Costa yep
she's the voice you hear singing the
song
isn't that just gorgeous she does have a
beautiful voice doesn't she
Mary was 22 when she got her Disney role
here's Mary Kosta a couple of years
later talking about Sleeping Beauty I
didn't realize at the time I sang once
upon a dream that it would change my
life doesn't she have a wonderful
southern accent how cute is she she was
an absolutely perfect choice for Aurora
Ariel aha where do we begin with Ariel
her looks were based on the charmed
actress Alyssa Milano but that's not who
actually gave Ariel her voice
so who's the gorgeous voice behind this
classic song it's Jodi Benson here she
is
proving that she can sing as Ariel no
matter where she is including during an
interview
ah Jody is still very much involved in
the afterlife of the Little Mermaid and
she totally embodies this role Belle now
let's move on to the book-reading
princess we have a soft spot for Belle
and her adorable passion for books we
can't blame her really so who is the
voice behind this gorgeous Disney
character page O'Hara is her name and as
of 2018 she's 62 years old here she is
singing one of our most beloved songs
from Beauty and the Beast she's
definitely still rocking it isn't she
and just look how gorgeous she looks and
in case you're wondering her favorite
color is blue as a matter of fact she
wore something blue to her Belle
audition to the premiere and of course
Belle also wears blue it's a perfect
match in 2011 she accepted a Disney
Legend Award which was very much
deserved
Paige will also appear in the record
Ralph - movie where she'll pay homage to
her Belle character once again in fact
all voice-over actresses who are still
alive will be reprising their original
Disney roles Jasmine Princess Jasmine is
arguably one of the most gorgeous
princesses but she also has a good head
on her shoulders she knows exactly what
she wants and she isn't afraid to go
after it just check out how sassy she
can be here I'm rich - you know yeah
the daughter of a sultan the confidence
level is exactly why we love her so much
- Mew is played by the gorgeous Linda
Larkin she looks totally different than
her character doesn't she
but because Linda Larkin was only
providing Jasmine speaking voice I want
to thank you for stopping that man not
many people would have done that we
should also mention Leia Salonga the
famous pinoys singer is very well known
for her Disney roles just check her out
[Music]
isn't she a fantastic singer we can
definitely see why Disney chose her to
do the singing part even so Linda Larkin
is still extremely thankful for her
speaking role of jasmine what do you
think should every Disney voice actress
also sing her parts or is that not
necessary Pocahontas and we made it to
Pocahontas if you've seen our previous
Disney Princess videos you know that we
struggle picking our faves but
Pocahontas is pretty high up there well
I'm running through the woods and then
right there in front of me is an arrow
we're still not sure if it was good to
save John Smith especially after hearing
the original Pocahontas story but that's
not what this video is about we're here
to talk about this wonderful person
Irene do you want anything mm-hmm
what her name is Irene Bedard what's
special about her
is that our Veen is actually a Native
American herself which gave her a chance
to portray a ton of Native characters in
the right way unlike some of the other
Disney princess voice-over actresses
Irene didn't have to sign that Disney
contract you know the one that forced
you not to act in any other roles after
Disney in fact she's still a very active
actress you'll also be able to catch a
glimpse of her voice in wreck-it Ralph
too and we honestly can't wait for that
movie to come out what kind of a
princess are you
Milan speaking of progressive princesses
Mulan really changed the game didn't she
she was definitely the one that made us
as young kids see that we don't really
need to stick to our stereotypical
selves you can be whoever you want to be
and guess who gave Mulan her voice this
gorgeous lady
do you know her name it's meme now win
if she looks familiar
you probably saw her in Marvel's agents
of shield as Melinda may they'll never
take us alive
really
a little over the top don't you think
but yep she's also the original Mulan
well she only gave the popular character
her speaking voice they guess he was the
singer behind the voice it was the same
singer who gave her singing voice to
Jasmine that's right Lea Salonga is just
way too talented Ming Na win is actually
extremely grateful for her Disney role
here is pretty much what sums up Mulan
Ming will come for traymor LAN once
again in wreck-it Ralph - and we can't
wait Tiana
so Mulan is definitely a progressive
princess but Tiana is without a doubt
one of the most underrated ones you need
napkin sweetheart I'm gonna work a
double shift event hey hot cakes this
hard worker deserves far more than
people give her credit for a princess
with a dream to run her own restaurant
come on that's pretty much unheard of
these days but do you know who you
should also give more credit to anika
Noni Rose she's the voice behind the
gorgeous Tiana and Anika is just as
gorgeous and talented as her Disney
Princess character here she is accepting
her Tony Award for her role in Caroline
or change here she is singing one of our
favorite songs almost there
this video belongs to inside the magic
who once again gave us some extra disney
magic with this clip
[Music]
[Applause]
seriously princess and the frog is
definitely one of the most underrated
Disney movies ever rapunzel tangled was
the modern Disney movie that definitely
changed the game it's one of our faves
and a must-see if you love to get catchy
tune stuck in your head all day come on
you know you love this one a lot of
people don't seem to realize that the
voice behind Rapunzel is actually Mandy
Moore yep Disney actually got a singer
who was pretty popular in the 90s she
even got to play Rapunzel in tangled the
series that's enough Varian in case
you're not familiar with Mandy she got
one of her first roles in the one and
only Princess Diaries
she played Lana Thomas still doesn't
ring a bell
this might help
do the coop stop it you may face it you
love the stupid Cupid song - can you
believe that Rapunzel was actually in
Princess Diaries and of course because
Mandy was a good singer she was also
able to sing Rapunzel's parts herself
and honestly we wouldn't have it any
other way
Merida seriously when it comes to modern
princesses we can never decide on our
favorite because there's just so many
but Merida would definitely be high up
there she's just one of those
progressive princesses you can't help
but love and who is responsible for this
adorable Scottish accents and I started
spoke to this person for 10 minutes and
they just burst out laughing when I
eventually found to feel stop her name's
Kelly McDonald's and yep she's actually
Scottish did you know that she also
portrayed Helena ravenclaw in the second
part of Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Kelly said she loves Merida
because she's able to make her own
mistakes and learn from them which
definitely makes her very much human of
course we'll also be hearing Kelly again
in wreck-it Ralph - which is absolutely
fantastic who could possibly forget
about this glorious scene give mommy a
key sheet undone topic be no Jin chai -
didn't honor and here comes the
unofficial princess that's guilty for
making us sing this for the rest of our
lives let's be honest onna definitely
deserves to be on the disney princess
list she did a fantastic job on his
voice is actually portrayed by the one
and only Kristen Bell yep the Kristen
Bell that loves sloths and the one that
gave her voice - the one and only Gossip
Girl oMG you're not going to believe who
Gossip Girl is Kristen is
well-established as a Hollywood actress
apart from her role as Ana and being on
Gossip Girl
she's also most well known for her sassy
role as Veronica Mars plus she's
absolutely hilarious
here she is singing do you want to be a
snowman as all frozen characters
do you wanna build a snowman isn't that
adorable Kristen will of course return
as Ana on wreckit-ralph 2 if you can't
get enough of her you'll probably also
be excited to hear that the Veronica
Mars series got revised and we'll play
on Hulu soon Elsa sure most people don't
think Elsa and Anna deserve a spot as
official Disney Princesses well they're
not but Elsa did make us sing let it go
forever and let's be honest it's still
stuck in our heads
[Music]
come on she deserves to be on this list
also singing and speaking voice belongs
to idina menzel yep the one that had to
unfortunately witness this mishap please
welcome the wickedly talented one and
only a dozen yeah he meant to say idina
menzel but of course Adina has a
fabulous sense of humor and she didn't
take this to heart but apart from this
mishap Adina is one of the most adorable
humans you'll ever meet
here she is getting her Tony Award in
2004 and to be in the company of these
women this evening is a dream thank you
so much frozen wasn't Adina's first and
only disney gig in fact she's actually
done plenty of other movies and if he
paid close attention you could even hear
her singing in the hercules TV series
she might have played an ice queen with
a broken heart and a need to let it all
go but let's be honest Adina deserves a
spot as the official Disney princess
whoa at least Elsa does
who's your favorite Disney Princess
actress come talk it out in the comments
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]